[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my 56th
episode of dirty chest tricks today I am
so excited to share some of my own
research in a very little known but
tricky line
Napoleon attack the opening arises after
the falling model Knight to c3 and we
are only looking at the movie Phi
however if you open and continue with
other popular choices then stay tuned
guys as by end of this lecture
I am going to show you my own
recommendation against this popular
choices okay 'if i Knight to f3
attacking only Phi and that means by
force black has to play Knight to c6
which is the only decent reply few
pursue players has played the move d6
but after the move d4 it is white who
enjoy the space and dictate the game
early in the opening stage a sample line
can goes like this pawn takes d4 Knight
takes d4 and after Knight to f6
you can simply continue with E for
grabbing space in the center and as I
have highlighted over here you can see
once white castle with the space in the
center it is only white who can press
the gear and enjoy the attacking stuff
so that's the reason why in the database
99% of the game continued it Knight to
c6 defending on e5 and here comes the
starting position of the tricky nipple
in attack with the move d4 what I like
about this line is from the opening it
is very forceful and by force released
to this critical moment again black
can't play d6 the simple reason is after
pawn takes e5 Knight takes e5 Knight
takes e5 pawn takes e5 we can simply
exchange the Queen and not only black
king is misplaced but why can quickly
castle on the Queen side and all these
positions it is only black who is
surviving for the draw so that means
again black responses force black has to
take on d4 and after that white is going
to simply recapture with the night which
brings us to the starting point of the
Napoleon tricky lines and as I have
highlighted over here black has mainly
five different choices and amongst them
Knight to f6 and Bishop to c5 are the
most popular one but let's see each bite
on starting with the least popular
choice the first move I want to consider
is Quint web six which is in fact a
dubious move and the ref edition goes
with Knight to be fine a checking on c7
and it doesn't matter whether black
continued it king to d8 or the move
Bishop to c5 the oral result will be the
same for example the most popular choice
in this position is Bishop to c5 so
black is saying hang on chump you can't
take on c7 as I'm threatening on
- but guess what white going to counter
reply wits
nope sweetie I'm going to take on c7
with a folk and once your King moves on
D age now comes the star mu e 3 ha ha ha
and black to his horror realized that he
can't take on c7 as his Queen is going
to lost on the next move with Knight to
d5 the best black and do over here is
rook to b8 saving the rook but then
white can take out his knight in a style
with Knight to d5 and once the Queen
move just within the seventh move of the
game white emerge with an extra pawn and
not only that black king is completely
caught at the center of the board the
second move I want to consider is D Phi
which is again look more natural in
these positions black is freeing up his
two bishops but the problem start with
White's next reply that is Bishop to f4
black has to play a six as in one blade
game one of my opponent continued eight
Bishop to d6 which turn out as a big
time disaster as again the tricky
Napoleon trick comes into the table with
yup night can testify and white emerge
with an extra ball the point is after
Bishop captures f4 you can't take on f4
immediately but you have this
intermediate move Knight captures c6
attacking the Queen and after pawn takes
c6 and the moon night capsules f4 on top
of everything black has a shattered pawn
on the Queen side which put him in a
really horrible state and this pawn
structure demolition team crop up often
and often in the knuckle and attack
which you have to watch out you know
most all the variations
okay so a success must stopping night to
be five and now we can make it very easy
Knight captures e6 pawn capture c6 and
Queen to d4 taking the central stage and
as I have highlighted over here but has
a very simple plan to execute namely
efore and castle and no matter whatever
black plays he's having a hard time
defending his center for example one of
my own game continued with Bishop to e6
I simply responded with Evo and now
black really doesn't want to capture on
e4 as again his shattered coincide pawn
more than enough to lose the game so in
the game he played the obvious move
Knight to f6 keep defending on defy but
after castle on the Queen side no matter
whatever black plays Queen to e4 is an
agenda and what else but black is in a
huge trouble I like to quickly point out
what is the danger in the game my
opponent fed up with all this and he
continued it CFI attacking my queen but
that just encouraged me to play the moon
Queen 24 with check and after Bishop to
d7 now you will see the point behind
Queen going to the a file as after Queen
to e5 suddenly my opponent realize that
he is going to lose the pawn and
something he can't do anything about it
he played c6 but after Queen exchange
and then taking on defy at the end of
the whole sequence white again emerged
with an extra pawn and a far better
position
the third move I want to consider is
Bishop to b4 pinning down the white nine
and trying to give a structural
weaknesses on the queenside
but no matter as we are going to strike
first with night capture c6 here a black
simply recapture this night then after
Queen to d4 attacking to spawn so black
responses force black has to take on c3
but then we can simply recapture with
our queen and not only white octane the
bishop pair but again those structural
weaknesses can create some nasty
headache for the black cap
so this variation is right out of the
equation the correct response is a
plaque has come this far then he has to
execute what he wants to do namely
Bishop kept a c3 check destroying White
Queen side and now take back the night
with the people well as I mentioned
earlier the bishop pair factor is in our
favor but there is more to this position
as what can continue it
efore and no matter however black
continues he is going to have a
difficult time in the upcoming middle
game for example after Knight to f6 we
are going to continue with Queen to d4
and black is forced to play at 6 in this
position as he continued with other
moves let's say if defy then we can play
Bishop to e3 stopping him to castle so
that is not desirable and if he castles
then this pin is very annoying with
Bishop to g5 and after any black moves
let's say d6 we can exchange everything
on f6 and now it is black who has really
really horrible pawn structures which is
more than enough to get a losing
position in such endgame scenarios
[Music]
you
so no black can't allow Bishop g5 so at
6:00 is must in this position and it
looks like after this
why doesn't have any tricks left right
guess what you are completely wrong as
white can create more deadly problems
for the blacking with Bishop to e3
stopping to Castle so d6 is the obvious
response but that just allow us to hit
back in the center yep you're absolutely
right if I and no matter how we were
black plays he get on losing position at
first sight it looks like c5 is a very
good response right planting the bishop
and counter attacking the Queen but
guess what
it's a blunder by black and the response
is very obvious the shop captures c5
winning yet another bar the point is
after D cap to c5 we can exchange the
Queen and once again we can create this
horrible pawn structure which always
favors the white cap so that means black
has to play this only response Queen to
e7 telling white didn't you push this
pawn too far and now I'm going to grab
it and yes indeed at first sight this
mooo looks so good except there is one
problem that white has this equally nice
move King to d2 believe it or not and
the threat is very obvious
rook to even and black is in a huge
trouble
the best black can do over here is pawn
takes e5 brothel Bishop takes pawn takes
and the move Bishop captures f6 when
black recaptured this Bishop we can
straighten up our pawn structure and
that pawn structure demolition team
crops up again and again in all these
variations
finally guys we are reaching to the main
line moves and the fourth move I want to
consider is night to have six and again
stage my recommendation is you should
continue with Bishop to g5 pinning down
this AB six night now black has to play
Bishop to b4 but there's a nasty trick
exist if your opponent continued with
Bishop to e7 which looks more natural in
this position but in fact after Knight
to a5 now it looks completely stupid the
point is when black defends the g7 with
castle on the Kings side we can lop up
this mission and after Queen takes White
has this typical idea Knight to d5 which
by force destroy the White King side a
sample line can goes like this Queen to
e5 Bishop takes f6 pawn takes f6 and now
the move III which confirms white
winning advantage
okay so Bishop to b4 is the most
accurate choice and against this if you
have seen the earlier variation I don't
think so you have any problem you can
easily guess where its next reply yup
it's Knight captured c6 if B capture c6
then Queen to d4 and white position is
button so by force black has to capture
on c3 destroying white pawn structure on
Queen side and now again he has to take
with the peep on which allow us to
execute the demolition job on the King
side with Queen to d4 doesn't matter at
6 or castle
we can take on absence another queen
takes time and time we can destroy black
pawn structure and the important point
you have to remember is it is white who
is the first one to occupy the B file
which gives him the long-lasting
advantage last but not least what
happens if you open and continue with
Bishop to c5 well we are going to reply
with this tricky move Knight to a5 which
for the board not easy to dealt with
kindly note that if you open played
image of g6 then we have this typical
Knight maneuvering idea which gives Y a
clear nagging gauge so accordingly Queen
to f6 is the most popular choice in
these positions the idea is very simple
you are attacking this night and the
knight cannot move as devastation happen
one after well by far if you look at
this position in database all the games
continue with E 4 but that is not
something I am going to recommend in
this video as I come up with my own pack
line starting with G 4 so White's idea
is very obvious black can't play the
move G 6 as after Knight to d5
this Queen has to passively retreat to
the dear square which gives him a very
good advantage so accordingly two moves
make it sense in this position the first
move I want to consider is Bishop to b4
pinning down the c3 Knight but as black
wasted so much time with this bishop I
recommend this simple response Bishop to
d2 threatening Knight to d5 and after
Knight to e7 we can simply hit back this
Bishop V
a three black really do not want to take
on c3 and take pressure on g7 so Bishop
to e5 is obvious response but after
following sequence such as nightcap to
z7 black is forced to capture with the
night and now III and as I've shown here
once you play the move Queen to e2
Bishop to g2 and castle on the Queen
side with h4 white get tremendous space
on the King side and altogether this
position always sounds battle to the
white kam due to his extra piece and
development and space on the Kings side
the most interesting position arises on
the board when black continue with
Knight G to e7 stopping over Knight to
d5 idea where our Knight strike with a
different angle Knight to e4 hitting the
two big guys well if black allow us to
capture the bishop then white position
is obviously quite better so accordingly
the accurate response goes as follows
Bishop to b4 check c3 and now Queen to
e5 counter attacking the knight so black
can argue that I am happy to give up the
bishop pair but in return I'll win some
of your pawns when okay no issues as we
are going to take this bishop and after
Queen takes e4 here comes the move which
can be easily missed over the ball and
that is Intermezzo Knight captures g7
check King to f8 and now f3 saving all
the threat well yes
black and grab one more porn with Queen
captures before but after Bishop to d2
Queen captures b2 and now star mu bishop
to at six and even though black is a
quite a material ahead his king is not
going to survive for a long time in fact
I have reached this position against a
twenty three hundred rated opponent and
I like to show you this game which
finished very quickly which shows the
potential of this line in the game
my opponent get out of the check
immediately with King to g8 but then he
has to face this nasty move Knight to h5
and you can see there are nasty threats
are looming and black is completely
helpless to stop them well he tried the
move d6 liberating his LightSquared
bishop and as for the engine
efore is a best reply which I don't
quite understand but I played the
practical move Quintus even trying to
completely deflect black Queen now Queen
has to safeguard to square so my
opponent naturally played the move Queen
to e5 saving everything but after Bishop
to g7 Quinn to e6 and now Queen to be -
suddenly that truck in the corner as a
complete kaanum and the insult to the
injury when my opponent continued with
Knight to g6 thinking there okay I will
be only exchanged down for a couple of
pawns but after Bishop captures a shade
he indeed realized that he can't even
touch that Bishop due to the simple
Queen to g7 checkmate well f6 played in
the game but after Queen takes Queen
takes and now Bishop takes
when the dust is clear quite simply
emerge with a whole hookup now before we
leave I like to quickly give my
suggestions what you should play if you
open and continue with other popular
choice
apart from ePHI the first move is very
easy if c5 happens then you can simply
response with E for and now you can
decide whether you want to play open
Sicilian or closed to sing in okay what
about D Phi well against this my
recommendation is you can simply respond
with d4 so threat is c4 so naturally
when blacks top this with Knight to f6
we can play Bishop to g5 and this is
known as Vera so attack which is a quite
nice attacking opening system by white
and you can certainly refer some of the
videos and books which can give you a
healthy attacking recruiter in this line
last but not least when your opponent
plays the move Knight to f6 which is a
very flexible move my recommendation is
you should respond with equal
if black continued it if I then you can
choose between three nights with Knight
to f3 or Bishop's opening with Bishop to
c4
so that is within of a recruit ow and I
have covered a detailed video about this
lines so that's not an issue the only
critical line you have to study is what
happens when you opponent plays the move
D Phi which transpose into the
Scandinavian variation of other kind
defense well the simplest response is
ePHI and again this lines are slightly
better for the white cam and you can
definitely check out the theory section
that's it guys I hope you enjoy an on
this wonderful tricky but very rare
Napoleon attack I hope with this mini
lecture now you are confident enough to
play this line over the board and get
some nasty victories under your belt
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will make you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care